'l'annonce la plus attendue du président
russe concernés l'extension de la
période de confinement étant donné qu'en
russie le pic de l'épidémie n'a pas
encore été franchie cette période de
confinement devait initialement se
terminer au 30 avril et a donc été
repoussée de presque deux semaines
jusqu'au 11 mai nous allons bientôt
avoir les fêtes de mai et donc les
journées de travail 6 7 8 mai nous
savons que d'habitude
souvent les gens prennent des journées
de congé ou chaumet et aujourd'hui étant
donné le risque qui demeure jeu se
propose de déclarer ces trois jours
chômés avec maintien du salaire c'est à
dire que l'ensemble des fêtes de mai
sera jusqu'au 11 mai compris cearà
période chômée
vladimir poutine ensuite fait savoir que
des recommandations concernant les
étapes de déconfinement allaient être
transmises aux gouverneurs des régions
au cas par cas
en effet la situation dans les régions
est très variable certaines pourraient
voir leurs périodes de confinement
allongé tandis que d'autres au contraire
pourrait voir les restrictions
progressivement levé et je j'enjoins
lagence de sécurité de la consommation
d'ici une semaine pour le 5 mai
d'émettre des recommandations des
critères sur les étapes détaillées deux
sorties du confinement
il est évident que en fonction de la
situation épidémiologique et des
prévisions qui ont été faites
nous nous adapterons
donc les recommandations de vente est
envoyé aux régions le plus tôt possible
pour que les régions et en plus une
semaine supplémentaire d'ici le 11 mai
pour s'adapter pour adapter ses
décisions en fonction de leur situation
locale au-delà de cette annonce le
président russe à l'augmenter fait le
point sur l'évolution de la pandémie en
russie et les réponses apportées par les
autorités
il a au passage souligné que toutes les
ressources sont mobilisées pour faire
face à cette crise sanitaire
ce qui a permis au système de santé je
cite d'augmenter sa marge de sécurité de
façon significative
autre priorité du gouvernement maintenir
l'emploi et les salaires
à ce titre l'admirent poutine a demandé
à ses ministres de préparer un nouveau
paquet de mesures de soutien à
destination des auto entrepreneurs et
des pme une des catégories de la
population qui souffre le plus des
conséquences de ce qu'on filme